today we are fortunate to have Professor
Bob Groberg who's going to talk about
what he calls a collision of two
obsessions his obsession for physics
because he's a fantastic professor of
applied physics here at Yale
he's also aficionado so tell us about
this morning do I need this because it's
my boys good luck hey Chris yeah can we
turn this down with it because right
it's going to be definitely right all
right good morning and and welcome here
as thank you for inviting me so I'm
going to tell you today about my two
obsessions and they are physics and golf
and I just want to give you a little
background so when I was a kid I grew up
with the goal of being a golf
professional and I've played a lot of
golf and then I even went to college
with the goal of being a golfer that's
what I always wanted to do and and when
I got to college I was fortunate enough
to go to a place where they actually
made me study and and I figured out that
actually I really really also loved
physics and so I gave up my notion of
being a golfer and then went and did
physics and physics is way fun we build
all sorts of crazy experiments and
sometimes even blow things up
but you know you never lose the love of
what you do when you're a kid and in my
case it was golf and so I've always done
in physics and golf and part of that is
building little experiments that go in
golf clubs so I've been doing this for a
long long first off let me ask so uh I
want to understand who we have here so
tell me how many kids are in elementary
school
what grade fourth grade third grade sit
okay so how many men in middle school
let me see middle school good and this
is sixth seventh and eighth grade right
right and then how about high school all
right okay so who here can tell me what
physics is anybody know anybody wicked
yes come on Marcus go ahead let me hear
what's that study of energy good that's
really good because once that's really
good let's hear another idea whoa did
everybody hear that
the science of moving objects that is
great man I'm going to we got to get him
a t-shirt that was great go ahead get it
up did you ever hand up you're going to
say the science moving off okay good
so physics is a lot of things but today
let's just talk about physics in terms
of the science of moving objects because
in the end that's what a golf ball is at
least when you hit it and and everything
the golf club does before you hit it
hopefully it's a moving object and so
we're today we're going to talk about
the science and what I love that the
science of moving objects so in this
golf club is a little experiment and I
just want to show you there's a little
experiment in here and you know I'm a
physicist so my whole my whole view of
the world is that we should really take
data and understand really how things
are moving and
it turns out you can get sensors to
measure how things are moving all over
the place so it turns out I took a
sensor that's used in your car so
everybody who has a car how many people
have airbags in their car good so it
turns out your airbag has a little thing
called an accelerometer that's a fancy
fancy name but can anyone tell me what
it's so it's something that measures
acceleration and does anybody know a
simple way to describe acceleration
what's acceleration that is really great
the increase or decrease of the speed of
a moving object so if something is
speeding up it'll give you a big
measurement and if something is slowing
down it'll give you another kind of
measurement and what will it give you of
something just moving at the same speed
if it's not changing speed just moving
at the constant speed zero what grade
are you in seven K you know this is
really great mind talk is usually
focused on I give this talk to golfers
and you know adult golfers but I may
have to pick the level up for this group
yeah okay so there are accelerometers on
here and accelerometers are great
because they tell you when things are
speeding up and when things are slowing
down and in particular I have two
accelerometers on here I have one
accelerometer all the way down at the
end and I have one accelerometer all the
way up at the top and I'll show you why
that is and so there's a nice little
experiment people up in the front can
seen you come down later and look
there's a little circuit board that we
made and has a little microprocessor on
it we programmed that to communicate
with the sensors and then it has a
little wireless transmitter on it just
like the Bluetooth that you use for
wireless for your phone it's a very
similar thing and and so it's a little
experiment built into a golf club so
physics and golf so now let me show you
how this experiment works
and now this is always the very exciting
point any talk so you know you put these
systems together and then you push the
button and and you hope that the whole
thing works
whoa it's not all on the screen is it
yeah but that didn't do it
I lost the bottom part what's that
okay so I'm going to have to this is the
beautiful thing here properties that
bear with me here
we're going to get this to work you know
why because we're scientists
ah okay alrighty so what you see on the
left is what we call a little chart
recorder and you can see that in fact I
can turn it off and I can turn it on so
it really is working if anybody says
they're doing an experiment live ask
them to turn it off see if it's really
working okay and you can see that in
fact this is a measurement that measures
something about my golf swing and in
particular if I'm swinging slowly you
have a small thing and as I swing faster
it's bigger and bigger and I can make it
really really big and so let me just
increase the gain a little so we can see
all of it there we go
alrighty so we are so it's little
measurement now it's a it's a fancy kind
of measurement because first off it's
measuring acceleration so let's see we
have a couple people in high school
might have taken high school physics so
first off note that it doesn't measure
that and note that it doesn't measure
this
alright everybody see that what it does
measure is this right so the way these
sensors are put up it in here I measure
what kind of motion so this is called
rotational motion the measure motion in
a circle
I don't measure motion in a straight
line and the reason is because in the
golf swing
what is the golf swing mostly about
mostly about motion in a circle so these
sensors are arranged in a particular
configuration that allows you just to
measure circular motion does anybody
know what kind of acceleration that is
does anybody remember that term and
Euler acceleration how about the word
centripetal people so that's called
centripetal sometimes people call it
centrifugal but we prefer to call it
centripetal good so it's measuring
centripetal acceleration now you might
say well how is that going to be useful
to a golfer right because you know if I
swing a golf club I can't really look
and see what's going on there so we had
to figure out a way
take this data and make useful to the
golfer so who can guess what we did I
recorded it and mate okay good so maybe
I recorded it could build a head set
display into my glasses
I gave it a sound so you know when
you're hitting golf balls your eyes are
preoccupied because you're looking at
the ball and taste well it's kind of
hard to change the taste and you could
have like electrodes electrodes and do
some electroshock therapy but we didn't
do that instead what I did was the
following turn it into something that
you can hear because when you're hitting
golf balls for the most part your ears
are not being used and the ears are
really really good at hearing things in
picking out patterns so in order to get
the data to the golfer we turn it into
audio and in particular it's low pitched
and soft when you move slowly the faster
it moves higher the pitch and the louder
the sound right so now you have a way of
getting data immediately from the golf
club to the golfer and you don't even
really have to tell the golfer that it's
centripetal acceleration or that there's
two accelerometers and a microprocessor
and a wireless transmitter you can just
tell them what you're hearing is the
motion of your golf club and even
golfers can understand that everybody
good with that any questions about that
okay all right so it
okay so so I want to explain so now you
can ask well how is this useful to
golfers and so let me just give you a
couple of examples so the first example
is that the golf swing it turns out the
golf swing of really great golfers and
I'll tell you about that in a second
golf swing a really great golfers is
rhythmic that there's a particular
rhythm to the golf swing and it's not so
different than the rhythm of the
pendulum so this is a pendulum and it
turns out the rhythm of the golf swing
is pretty much the rhythm of the
pendulum
you'll hear the similarity there and
rhythm in tempo it turns out is very
important in the golf swing for reasons
of having to do with what makes you
consistent and we're going to talk about
that in great detail later but I just
want to motivate it so with beginning
golfers you get tempo which is not
rhythmic so that's a rhythmic tempo
right so here would be a typical
beginning golfer okay not very rhythmic
don't understand that it has to be
rhythmic but all good golfers swing with
a rhythm with a really good rhythm here
would be another one so why don't I hit
the golf ball far golf ball and go very
far right you want to hit the golf ball
far
if the swing of the hive faster pace
right so being able to hear the
difference in speed is a big thing being
able to hear that there's a real rhythm
in the golf swing and what by the end of
this talk hopefully you'll all
understand why you really want to real
rhythm in the golf swing there's another
really fun thing that you can hear you
can hear when the club gets to its
maximum speed right you hear that
maximum speed down here right down at
the bottom you hear the highest pitch
down by the bottom it turns out in many
many golfers especially the poorer
golfers you'll hear this you hear that
was way back here and you hear that so
they get their maximum speed way before
the golf ball and then even in the very
best of golfers sometimes you hear this
can you hear it out here you hear the
the maximum speed beyond the ball now
where where would you like to have the
maximum speed who can tell me right at
the ball but it turns out almost never
ever do people get their maximum speed
right at the ball so just something as
simple as that is really useful to
listen to
everybody good with that so far any
questions Iran fun yet get enough food
so you know so as an inventor you know
you spend lots and lots of years of
doing all this crazy stuff so I've been
putting sensors in golf clubs since 1993
how many of you were not yet born yet in
1993 right right so I've been doing this
for a long long time and it all seems
kind of crazy but you know you just keep
doing it because that's really what
science is about you just do what you
think is really interesting and
hopefully it turns out I'll have
application and this summer we were very
very lucky in that some some of our so
we started make taking it from something
like this it's something which is a real
product and we've had people all around
the really great golf pros use this
recently so I just want to give you one
example our best example you know in
science we always give our best example
so does anybody recognize this person
Vijay Singh right so of the many people
who've been using our stuff the person
who's used it the most as a scout Vijay
Singh and actually before the 17 months
prior to starting to use our stuff he
hadn't won a golf tournament and he
started using our equipment and about a
month later he won three out of five
tournaments in a row and he ended up now
he's number one on the money list and
he's and he just won the FedEx Cup and
he has widely claimed that in fact this
was due in part to our stuff and I want
you to read the quote because the quote
is going to be what we're going to talk
about for the rest of this talk we're
going to explain why it is that this is
all the case so I think it's helped me
tremendously so I've always had good
rhythm but I never had consistent rhythm
that making my swing a lot more that
it's making my swing a lot more
consistent not just with my driver the
whole game it's one rhythm for the whole
game instead of having quicker rhythm
for different shots so remember that
it's the same rhythm for the whole game
so we're going to talk about why that is
and what kind of experiment that we did
to understand why it's one rhythm
whole game and and then the next line is
it's making me more consistent and so
we're going to talk about why why what
it is about the golf swing and the golf
swing being rhythmic that makes you more
consistent there's two things we're
going to talk about today why it's one
rhythm for the whole game and why
swinging with that rhythm makes you more
consistent okay alrighty so now comes
the science part good with it not going
to do any more demos any questions
people are going on Science Park anybody
sleeping yet if they're no yeah yeah
so the USGA will not let you use any
external means to hit a golf ball if
you're playing in a tournament so they
use these mostly on the practice range
and sometimes if you are if you're
trying to take what you're learning to
the practice range to the golf course
then and in a practice round I'd be you
can take them on the golf course during
a practice round but if you're playing
in a tournament you can't use any
external means though you can take data
if you don't use it immediately
I mean people take video that's data
okay
so I want you to get used to what this
golf swing looked like so there's a back
swing here's the back so here's the data
that we were looking at before here's
the back swing the extend triple
acceleration in the backswing and then
you get to the top of the backswing and
then you come down into the ball and
then you follow through right so you
have a back swing top of the backswing
down into the ball after swing foibles
gotta look cool all right so now these
are 20 swings of my nephew that's what
when this was taken
a Jeff with 16 years old and he played
on his high school golf team and he
didn't know I was taking data at the
time but I was and what you'll notice is
that every one of his golf swings is a
little bit different so right we trigger
from here everything is the same at this
point that's how we line everything up
but if you go into the backswing or if
you go into the downswing everything
every single swing becomes a little bit
different and in particular he has two
different kinds of back swings it's got
a long back
and he's got this short backswing when
he thinks he's hitting it hard okay this
is what you see for seven swings of a
tour pro this is Pat McGowan who I used
to watch when I was growing up he was
the 1978 PGA Tour rookie of the year and
if you look at these seven swings what
do you notice
they are very nearly the same in fact if
you know the error bars associated with
these things are measured in terms of
tens of ten ten milliseconds so a
hundredth of a second that means each
swing is pretty much the same to within
a hundredth of a second I mean that's
pretty incredible but it's typical of
what you see of golf pros that is that
swing to swing to swing if they're very
good golf pros it's always exactly the
same and Pat's swing was kind of
interesting this is the back swing this
is the down swing anybody want to make a
guess at what that is
so his golf swing is always like this
every single time it gives it that
little thing what's that
Hey
so we can yep there that's impact so at
impact you get a little shock and the
sensors are not fast enough to measure
the full dynamic of the shock so just
look like random spikes the impact in
this case happens here and then the next
data point used to see a couple of
shocks through the system then it
follows there yep okay so let's take
some so let's take some data let's try
to really understand how precise this
guys swing is and in particular we're
going to look at all sorts of different
swings and we're going to measure the
length of the backswing so how many
seconds did it take for the backswing
and we're going to measure how many
seconds it took for the downswing and
we're going to do this for all sorts of
people and we're going to collect this
in this so this is a graph how many
people know about graphs good good okay
so this is the amount of time for the
backswing and this is the amount of time
for the downswing and each one of these
dots is a different person so this
person here took just over a second for
the downswing a backswing and just so
just about two hundred fifty a quarter
of a second for the downswing so we plug
back swing versus downswing for lots and
lots of different people and we divide
them into different groups Tour Pros and
really good golfers and just average
golfers and what you find if you just
look at this group of Tour Pros so this
is a whole bunch of different Tour Pros
they all pretty much swing exactly alike
that is the total amount of time for the
backswing in the total amount of time
for the downswing is pretty much the
same for all of them pretty incredible
the other thing you note here if you
look at these others let's see how their
error bars they're our error bars here
so each dot represents one person and
each dot represents maybe like 20 swings
or thirty swings for one person because
as a scientist you don't just take one
data point you take lots of data points
and then you can take averages you can
say what's the average backswing and how
much does it vary and the error bars or
how much they vary what do you notice
about the error bars for these people
very very very small error bars which
means they're very consistent every
swing from swing to swing the swing is
almost exactly the same
and if you and the other thing so very
small error bars all pretty much exactly
the same timing or rhythm of their swing
but if you look at these are now golf
professionals who don't play for a
living they give lessons and they run
golf courses and they used to long ago
maybe play for a living and what you see
first off is that the error bars get
bigger for these people right from swing
to swing they're not as consistent and
the other thing you'll see is that from
swing to swing they're slower so this
group here would be right about there so
as they start to get slower what you see
is the error bars start to get bigger
nobody's faster than the Tour Pros those
guys swing as fast as anybody even
though they appear to be swinging slowly
and then here's the rest of us I used to
be much better now we can talk about
asking me that at the end of the lecture
I can show you how I've improved so I
had the date on that but you see forever
so the Tour Pros you hear everybody else
is slower and much more inconsistent and
now you can ask the question why is it
that these people are so consistent what
is it about the physics of how of the
science of how they move this object
what is it that makes them so consistent
and there are a whole bunch of things
that we'd like to explain why are they
so consistent why is it that they all
swing roughly with the same tempo what I
haven't told you yet is whether those
data were taken for a 5-iron or a driver
or a 9-iron or different shot in the
answer is it doesn't matter it's all
pretty much the same whether it's a
5-iron or a driver whether it's a
three-quarter shot or a full shot it's
all pretty much the same and so you can
ask what's the science of that
there are two different groups very good
and I don't know why that is I don't
know if that's just because I didn't
take data on enough people or if there
really are two different groups
good good notice good observation okay
so so now who can tell me something
which is really ready so we want to do
this from a science perspective can we
make a model of the golf swing which
really has all of this science built
into it so who can tell me something
that's real that science thing or a
physical thing that's really consistent
has exact tempo or it keeps time the
same way every single day anybody go
ahead a clock exactly right so you can
ask the question you can maybe rephrase
this and to say you know these golf pros
kind of behave like clocks in the sense
that they always have the same tempo so
you can ask the question well what's the
physics of a clock what's exactly the
physics of a clock so it turns out the
physics of a clock is something that we
call we have a big fancy name for it in
science we call it the harmonic
oscillator and a harmonic oscillator
another way of so that's a big fancy
word and we use big fancy words as a
means of job security in this field but
really it just means a mass in a spring
and and and a mass so you know if you
have like a slinky with a mass attached
to it you'll know that this you the
slinky you'll bounce back and forth
exactly and it'll go back and forth sort
of always at the same tempo now a spring
is something as it is a just an image
for something that always pulls you back
to the origin so you can start at the
origin and go away and pull and the
spring just always pulls you back so it
turns out the model of the harmonic
oscillator or the mass and a spring is a
pretty good model for almost anything
that once you pull it away from the
origin wants to come back so for
instance the pendulum
so what pulls the pendulum back to the
origin gravity exactly man a kid gets
two t-shirts so gravity pulls the
pendulum back to the origin so you can
model this is just a mass in a sprint
the mass is the mass of the club and the
spring is gravity pulling it back now
one of the properties that you notice
about this is that this has a peer up
tempo that it wants to go at and the
tempo is defined by it by its mass and
by how hard gravity pulls back and it
really it's its length but we won't go
there but it turns out it has a
particular frequency that it wants to go
at we call this the resonant frequency
this is what driving it at this
frequency is what we call resonance now
I can drive this at a different
frequency I can go much much much much
slower but you notice I have to grab on
with my hand to do this it takes a lot
more energy to drive it really slowly
and you'll notice that it isn't as
regular as it if I just drive it at
resonance because when it goes at
resonance
it just goes at the frequency that it
wants to go at and I can do this today
and I can do this an hour from now and I
can do this next week and I can do this
when I'm in a good mood and I can do
this when I'm in a bad mood and when I'm
tired and went on and when I have a lot
of rest and it will always go back and
forth at this pace because that's what
it is to drive it at resonance
I can always drive it above resonance
and that looks horrible right when you
drive it at resonance it actually looks
pretty smooth and it doesn't really look
like I'm working hard and in fact the
way you find resonance is simply figure
out where you go back and forth putting
in the least amount of energy that's so
I can do this with two fingers but if I
try to move slower than that I can't do
that without holding on with my whole
hand takes a lot more energy to do this
takes very little energy to drive
something in resonance so resonance is
really neat in that you don't have to
use a lot of energy to drive things at
resonance and and it'll always be very
very very consistent do you have a
question
pretty good really good so alright so
the harmonic oscillator now it turns out
we tell our students in introductory
physics you can model almost the entire
world using the harmonic oscillator in
fact you can spend your whole life as an
engineer or scientist and know no other
model than the harmonic oscillator in
fact I would argue it's one of the few
models that we really know how to solve
exactly and so it's a wonderful model
for the golf swing you can ask yourself
the question are golfers clocks in the
sense that they move the golf club like
a harmonic oscillator like a mass on a
spring okay so what would be that what
would be the model of how a golfer
swings a golf club so you can imagine
this is the golfer and this mass here
includes not just the club but also the
strength of the books the strength of
the arm the arm the mass of the arms and
the torso and the whole thing and the
spring is a combination of gravity and
the muscles pulling back and you can
imagine that as you wind up the golf
swing that it's like compressing a
spring and you push back with a force
and then when you come down the other
way you turn the force around and push
the other way right so that's my model
for the golf swing you push back
initially and then you push down now
does anybody see that there's what we
call an asymmetry here if you look at
the first time you're pushing are you
compressing the spring or expanding the
spring so to begin with you're pushing
against the spring and then afterwards
you're pushing with the spring right and
so let me do that again so initially you
push against the spring you compress it
and then you expand it you push with the
spring and so that's very different
thing in one case you're compressing
another expanding and so it turns out
you would expect that there's a
difference in the amount of time to go
back and the amount of time to come
right if one case you're compressing the
spring in the other case you're going
with the spring there'll be a difference
in time and it turns out we can calc I'm
not going to show this turns out we can
calculate that and it turns out that if
you push back with exactly the same
force that you push down that the back
swing will be twice as long as the
downswing and it turns out that if you
push back with half the force that you
pull down and pull down twice as hard as
what you pull back the ratio of
backswing to downswing will be about
three to one and it turns out three to
one is the ratio that we see for good
golfers that in those graphs that I
showed you earlier the amount of time to
go back is about three-quarters of a
second and the amount of time to come
down is about 1/4 of a second and
there's a ratio of three to one and it
turns out the harmonic oscillator model
says that if you pull down twice as hard
as what you push back you'll get this
the ratio of three to one so it actually
looks like it might be a pretty good
model so we have reason to believe that
it's useful but we had to go measure
that oh so I started talking to people
about this model for golfers and Springs
and a lot of golfers said that was crazy
in fact I had one golfer look at me and
say a really really great teaching pro
looked at me and said look no spring
right he was right I mean that's pretty
distressing I got this big model for how
we're a mass and a spring and everything
goes back and it goes back and says look
no spring pretty hard to argue with that
right so I went and started talking to
lots of people about this and in fact
some professors here and here's the
thing we're how many people here are
athletes
okay so here's here's the lesson I want
you to take from this lesson from this
lecture is that the thing that make
that's different about elite athletes
the best athletes from everybody else is
that they learn to use their bodies as
Springs that is they learn to drive
their bodies at the natural resonances
of their body it doesn't matter what
your whether what you're doing is
running or jumping or swinging a golf
club that elite athletes the best
athletes work right at resonance and
they work right at resonance because
it's the most efficient way to work and
everybody and that's why they always
looks
a smooth and they always look so
graceful because they are because
they're working right at resonance and
everybody else looks klutzy because
we're doing this we're trying to go fast
and we're doing this and really what we
should be doing is this and that's what
you see in in great athletes that they
all move resonantly I do have an answer
I do have an answer
you bet so so let me just show you that
in fact you know we're scientists so we
have this idea that the body works like
a spring but you really want to prove
that that's going to be the case so you
have to go back and figure out how to
make a measurement to measure to
determine whether that's really how the
body moves so that's in fact what we did
and I'll just show you the example so
here is my laboratory at one point in
time it was all filled with lots of
wonderful optics and we did all sorts of
great optics of quantum mechanical
systems we had lots of big words that
enable job security all of that stuff
but ultimately we decided we had to make
some measurements related to the golf
swing and so I moved all that fancy
equipment out of the way and put up a
golf net and okay I kind of got away
with that so here's a golfer this was a
golfer from the Yale golf team and we
conceived of the following experiment so
if you're really a spring if they're
golf if torso really is a spring let's
apply a force and then watch how that
spring moves right so if this is a
spring I can apply a force and watch how
it moves so we did the same thing with
the golfer we asked the golfer to apply
a force back but we had to measure that
force first so we attached a rope to the
golf club and it had a little sensor
that measured how hard the person pulled
back and then while that person wasn't
paying attention we cut the rope and so
they'd be pulling back and pulling back
and pulling back and all of a sudden
they'd move because the Rope would get
cut and then we put a sensor on his back
to measure how his body moved nothing
you can't do with duct tape so this is a
sensor that's called a gyroscope and a
gyroscope measures how things rotate so
we had a little gyroscope on his back
and we had
several people do this over and over
again we'd ask them to apply a force big
four small force we didn't care we
measured how big a force they applied
and then we watched how their body move
and and if it behaves like a spring what
do we know the figure the force what
will happen if you apply a little force
how far will you move a little bit right
if you apply a bigger force what will
happen bigger right so the bigger the
force the further of the body would move
but what about the tempo should the
tempo matter whether it's a little force
or a big force if it's really moving in
resonance
no exit well great you in you are good
you're good so right it shouldn't matter
whether you apply a big force or a small
force if the body is really moving at
resonance then then it should always be
the same amount of time to go back so
that's the experiment we did and I'll
just show you here's some data so this
is the rotation of the body this is
standing still and this would be in the
back swing as it winds up and this is
the number of degrees so this torso
wound up about 70 degrees and then it
started to come down and all we did
first off is measure how far back does
it go
remember the more force the further back
it should go and the other thing we
measured is how long it took to get all
the way back now how long it should
always take the same amount of time to
measure how much force you apply and so
this is the amount of force we apply and
this is how long it took them to wind up
and what you see is as even as you
change the amount of force by a factor
of five or six really make the force
much bigger that it always takes them
out about the same amount of time for
them to wind up and that's a pretty good
indication that they're working just
like a spring because that really is a
property of the swing spring does
another how much force you apply it's
always going to take the same amount of
time to wind up and the other thing you
learn is that the amount of time to wind
up is about three-quarters of a second
which is what amount of time for the
backswing in a good golfers backswing so
pretty good indication that in fact when
a golf but when a good golfer makes a
backswing really what they're doing is
they're winding up the spring resonantly
and then we can then this curve is how
far the torso moves depending upon how
much force you apply and what you see
here is that in fact the if you start
with little force and then start
applying more force the torso winds up
further and further but there's a limit
to how far your torso goes right you
can't wind up all the way around that
would be a nightmare so in fact what you
find is that it kind of falls off here
now biomechanics people have measured
this they invented these torture devices
which they use with their graduate
students and they seek the graduate
students here and then they start to
apply force and they see how far the
graduate student winds up as a function
of how much force they apply there are
some grad students back there so I just
want to show you this data so this is
how much force they apply and this is
how far their torso rotates and this is
measurement done by you know real
biomechanics people and in fact we you
can use that data to explain our data in
fact how the torso really winds up but
to first order the torso really does
behave like a spring and and we believe
in fact that's why it is that got that
really great golfers and great athletes
generically are good at what they do
that in fact they learn to operate
resonantly and in the case of golfers
really great golfers they learned to
drive their golf swing resonant with
their resonant frequency of the torso
the arms the hands the whole thing as a
common resonant frequency and that's
where they drive it now as for the
question of the answer to the question
of my friend look no spring the answer
is you know I can do that with this too
I can drive this resonantly or I can
hold it here right you can teach your
body to drive the body resonantly
or you can do all sorts of [ __ ]
things and have muscles fire in all
sorts of crazy ways that don't drive it
resonantly and you end up with stuff
like this and that's what most people do
most people never are never in touch
enough with their body to actually drive
it resonantly that is pushed back when
it wants to wind up and push back down
when it wants
go the other way most people push back
and keep pulling and stop and then come
down in some sort of crazy fashion that
isn't resin that doesn't lead to
consistence he was exhibiting
non-resident behavior and I actually but
and so we've shown that this is true for
the golf swing we've also shown that
this is true for the putting stroke that
the best the very best putters in the
world drive their putters resonantly at
the resonant frequency of the putter in
a very specific way and in fact you know
there's a whole community within golf
they call it Zen golf and they live by
these principles which is you know your
body knows what to do get out of its way
stop talking to yourself get all the Fox
out of your head just let your body do
what it's supposed to do and you know I
really argue this is where physics and
Zen come together because what the Zen
people have been trying to get you to do
but haven't been able to say is drive
your body resonantly that's really what
they're trying to get you to do but
they've never studied enough sine it's
actually to understand that those are
the words so I think actually if physics
goes far enough out to the deep end
comes back in Zen okay I can talk for
hours on golf and science and I can talk
about all sorts of more things and I can
tell you lots of stories but I'm going
to stop now and entertain questions and
let's see and at people and so let me
just tell you some other things so
people want to stick around I'm happy to
talk for as long as you want to listen I
can talk about how we generate power in
the golf swing why it is that great
golfers generate more power and hit the
ball further than other people we have
that data I can talk about what it's
like to take an invention and try to
turn it into a little company I can talk
about all sorts of fun things